[Musique]
au delà des vastes étendues des sables
d'arabie que les hommes du désert
parcours
au delà des pleine de cailloux brûlés de
soleil que d'un comptable verrier
défendre il existe un pays cachés dans
les montagnes leur sim court le long des
rives de la mer rouge et la sépare de la
masse infinie des sables du plus
terrible des déserts le roomba la haye
nous sommes dans le royaume d'arabie
saoudite en arabie du sud
nulle voyageurs n'en a jamais foulé le
sol nu l'étranger n'y a jamais posé son
regard
car cette contrée fut longtemps
interdite
farouchement gardé par ses habitants
pourtant un homme a accepté de nous y
conduire
il était lui-même à la recherche de ce
pays de secret et avait entendu parler
d'un conteur qui en avait les clés parti
de ryad passant par ge est d'après de la
mecque
nous avons traversé la province du assir
pour rejoindre rabat et la région de
jizane aux confins du yémen après avoir
franchi le mont sauda le plus haut du
royaume à 3000 m d'altitude
nous avons découvert les commencements
du pays des mystères le pays des hommes
fleurs là nous avons rencontré le
goûteur aux mille et une histoires magie
de me recevoir dans votre honorable
demeure on m'a dit que vous étiez un
sage un érudit et je suis donc venu
jusqu'à vous car je m'intéresse au pays
des hommes fleurs existe-t-il vraiment
votre visite m'honore et grandit ma
maison à beaune un chat si allah le
tout-puissant me laver je veux faire en
sorte de ne pas décevoir vos attentes
oui en effet j'ai connu le père mais
dont vous parlez le peuple des hommes
fleurs avec bear de tous les peuples de
nos territoires il est le plus ancien
son origine remonte à la nuit des temps
aux époques argué vous savez les grecs
et les romains porter des fleurs dans
les cheveux
la couronne de lauriers de césar en est
un exemple eh bien les hommes fleurs
d'arabie n'ont jamais cessé d'importer
ils ont même passé maître dans cet art
c'est pour cela qu'on les appelle les
hommes fleurs et si l'on peut douter de
leur existence c'est parce qu'il se
cache dans les montagnes si on les voit
jamais c'est parce qu'ils sont jaloux de
leur territoire ils les défendent avec
les armes s'il le faut
car ce sont des guéri toutes ces armes
que je vois à accrocher sur vos murs
doivent garder cette date par exemple
que vous avez posé ici près de vous hors
du commun
mais parvenu à tact d'un temps bien
éloignés et avec elle sa longue
édifiante histoire elle aurait été fort
j'ai façonné et travailler avec grand
art elle appartenait un homme aimé
admiré et respecté par ceux de son clan
or un jour il advint que cet homme
mourut en la grâce et la miséricorde
d'allah et sa dague est longtemps restée
plongée dans l'obscurité jusqu'à
certains jours
[Musique]
cet homme disparu avec un fils qu'il
avait nommé fayçal il n'avait que six
mois la mort de son père au moment où
notre histoire commence ce fils avait
beaucoup grande ville et son histoire
mais chez les hommes fleurs fayçal
appartenait au clan deyres un clan
notoire pour son courage et sa
combativité
les rêves étaient réputés pour leur
gentillesse et le grand respect dans
lequel il tenait qu toutes les choses
vivant un homme fleurs commencent
toujours sa journée en se parant le
front d'un bouquet floral et parfumée
l'art et la manière de la rangée sur sa
tête des voiles au dehors le reflet
intérieur de son âme
quant à l'âme elle peut bien mourir car
elle à la promesse de renaître au
printemps prochain comme les fleurs
[Musique]
la mère de fayçal avait rapidement suivi
son père dans l'autre monde alors c'est
le grand-père qui veillait sur l'enfant
et l'a enseigné à ce fils son fils tu
tout ce qu'ils savaient de la vie des
hommes fleurs
la mam est grand père étant devenu âgées
fayçal s'occuper de lui à son tour ce
matin après brel aux manettes à la zone
arrière man il y en ait un matin entre
les matins il est ce que le jeune homme
comme le vieil homme attendait chacun de
son côté
depuis longtemps thomas samson lettre je
me alain il savait la news du jour
fayçal serait peut-être la vàd me jeff
otah beau c'est ce jour-là que la dague
des pères de fayçal et la sortie de long
et le groupe r s'adresse à fayçal en ces
termes
voilà devenu un réalisme office
alors il te faut savoir ce que ça sinon
qui sait tenir sa parole quand il a
donné
fayçal
recevez-le un grand honneur
pendant toute son enfance
on lui avait parlé d'un père qu'il
n'avait jamais connu maintenant les
rites et de sa dague marque d'autorité
et de tenues grand père si t'as fait ça
toute sorte de recommandations est la
plus importante à ses yeux de respecter
ces deux-là prend grand soin fayçal car
c'est elle qui te protège à elle
protégera ta famille elle sera la
gardienne de l'honneur de ton clan et de
ce que la vie mettra sous la protection
salle promis à son grand-père qu'il
serait digne de cette d'agde digne de sa
lignée est digne d'être un rêve au
milieu du clan des rêves
c'est ainsi mieux qu'un père pour son
propre fils le grand père s'était
adressé à fait sale et lui souhaita
aussi les paroles du sage que la paix et
la sécurité soit sur toi et autour de
toi
[Musique]
mon
oh
[Musique]
genou
puisqu'il était un homme à vidy grand
père il lui fallait un travail d'homme
et il avait envoyé fayçal dans la
montagne à plusieurs heures de marche
rejoindre les berges est parti en
transhumance
là où l'on un des buts du clan loin des
femmes est loin des siens
fayçal devait se mettre au service du
patron des berges et le très sage et
très renommé y a rien qu'on appelait
aussi le philosophe attendait déjà le
jeune fille elle est assez il a dit qu'à
simplement fayçal où il devrait se
rendre et ben mhenni et avec combien de
chaînes
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ainsi que ce jour là
fayçal s'est trouvé à la tête de 200
chèvres a mené jusqu'à très haut et très
loin d'un pâturage
d'après les indications du patron berger
elle me serai qu'à la tombée de la nuit
[Musique]
m
il
être riche ou pauvre n'a pas
d'importance aux yeux des rêves le coeur
la droiture la renommée de la famille
sont les vraies valeurs
avec ce robot cents chèvres on n'est
rien avec dix chèvres survie avec 20
points les fragiles avec 50 on peut voir
venir
au cours du dernier hiver une épidémie
avait abattu les chèvres de grand père
donnait un troupeau a failli salle
c'était aider sa famille sans lui faire
long
[Musique]
y'a rien avait donc envoyé fayçal vers
un pâturage éloigné si allouani qu'aucun
des bergers du clan des rêves ni avait
mis les pieds depuis plusieurs
transhumance se féliciter de l'avoir
perdu aucune bête pendant sa malgré sa
satisfaction
il arrive à ce client des étrangers au
clan barrer la route à ces chefs ils
étaient armés
[Musique]
fayçal n'avait pas le temps de faire
preuve d'héroïsme ses chèvres étaient en
train de s'en aller étouffant sa rage il
choisit de les ramener en sécurité puis
malgré sa honte et ne perdez pas une
minute pour retrouver ya rien et lui
raconter sa mésaventure
puisque c'était y'a rien qui l'avait
envoyé là bas
elle raconte tout ayala ils étaient
trois armées de fusils il les avait
saluées avec des paroles de paix
l'invitation
il leur avait dit qu'ils étaient en
territoire ait avait répondu que non il
était là chez eux
[Musique]
des étrangers sur les terres du clan
parvient pas il y avait là de quoi
déclencher un conflit qui c'est une
guerre entre clans
il valait de la prudence beaucoup de
prudence
ce territoire à parthenay torres depuis
des générations il n'avait aucune raison
d'y être et iard ya renvoya fayçal avec
un message pour les étrangers s'il
s'était égaré les wraith les aiderait à
retrouver leur chemin et les ramènerait
chez eux soit avec gentillesse soit avec
force
c'était à eux de choisir obéir à plus
sachez que soi est un devoir
incontournable chez les hommes fleurs
fayçal obéit donc haye arias mais au
moins il n'était pas très sûr de lui
les étrangers étaient 3 lui tout seul il
était armé l'avait menacé de 1000 mots
s'il osé revenir
il est retourné d'un autre côté
grand-père avait insisté pour qu'ils se
montrent dignes de la dague de son père
s'il le fallait il se retirait cette
date de son fort
à 10 h à 12 h en mairie de douala sa
williams
il était du clan des arts à manille un
clan normalement en paix avec les rex à
l'orée du système est heureux qu'on lui
ait laissé la vie sauve mais il
regrettait de ne pas avoir trouvé la
mort la date de son père était une
longue mais il y avait pire encore
porter un fourreau sans lame s'était
montré qu'il lui manquait quelque chose
et cette chose c'était l'honneur les n3
jeune effronté du clan à rahmani avait
volé une dague un fils de rex jetant sur
lui et autour de lui une très grave
humiliation sans le savoir ils savaient
aussi noué le destin de fayçal qui
allait bientôt apprendre qu'une
d'estimer quelles qu'elles soient sert
toujours de secret des saints rahmani se
disputer pour la dad
y'a rien avait décidé de laver l'affront
fait à fait ça il souriait le clan
entier il y avait aussi la question du
territoire
y'a rien avait demandé un fayçal de le
retrouver aux premières leur âge ou à la
croisée des trois wadi il consulterait
le chef de guerre du clan deyres le très
avisé et très redouté en mode a ou qu'on
appelait aussi le puits sans doute le
cap quand un chef de guerre est saisie
d'un conflit il lui faut tout entendre
contrôlez comprendre vérifier avant de
prendre une décision
une affaire d'honneur chez les hommes
fleurs peut mener rapidement au sang
versé il a donc fallu aux jeunes faysal
il répète encore son histoire et où elle
lui était arrivé
ouais compris le chef de guerre mode à
huy et qu'il ne s'agissait pas seulement
une affaire d'honneur il avait même
amour pour sa violation de territoire
c'était intolérable
[Musique]
rahmani étaient trois ils seraient 3
reste à les poursuivre
mme oda oui le puissant promettait déjà
d'accrocher leur tête au rocher des
foules tient derrière dû l'arrêter
il n'était pas question car à ys vs le
premier sens il fait promettre à madaoui
de regarder d'abord discuter si possible
et le faire parler les armes qu'en
dernier recours
le marron raconte que mme oda oui promis
taillard yade se retenir
en attendant il courait vers les lieux
de l'embuscade un seul chemin menait aux
grandes banques il ne pouvait pas rater
leurs ennemis
[Musique]
et les arts à manille s'était enfui il
devait savoir que leur forfait ne
pouvait rester impunie que les raïs
réagir est qu'ils trouveraient leurs
traces au qu'ils aillent
c'était très clair les ennemis avaient
eu peur de leurs fusils pour madame oui
ils étaient déjà rentrés chez eux d'ici
rahmani ne pouvait suivre que les gorges
jusqu'aux limites du territoire est ce
là bas la terre prenait fin laisser
place à un monde sans vie où personne ne
mettait jamais les pieds
léa rahmani avait fait preuve de lâcheté
ils n'oseraient pas s'y aventurer
ils étaient coincés ya rien et mme oda
oui pensez fayçal trop jeune pour mourir
les codes guerrier hommes fleurs étaient
strictes on ne tire pas sur un homme
sans arme n'ayant plus de dagg fayçal
tomber dans cette catégorie en le
laissant sans fusil moda oui le
préserver d'un tir ennemi gardant pour
lui et iard ya le risque d'être abattu
haut la main
[Musique]
nos trois amis avaient une certitude il
ne cesserait de marché qu en dénichant
les 3a rahmani ici ou ailleurs
s'ils étaient rentrés chez eux ils
iraient les déloger de leur campement
sous les yeux de leurs femmes et même de
leurs enfants
quand on fuit on a peu de solutions ça
le meneur des rahmani le savez il été
revu à la vidéo le son plot et est
simple trouver un lieu stratégique s'y
cacher et attendre avec l' avantage de
voir les wraith venir de loin
[Musique]
plus nos trois amis avançait plus il
s'éloignait de leur territoire plus il
se rapprochait de la culture
[Musique]
si le meneur des ennemis était rusé
modèle wi était un chef de guerre de
grande expérience
sans parler du talent légendaire des
hommes fleurs pour suivre une piste
qu'elle soit animale ou humaine dans
leur fuite et armani avait conduit les
wraith sur les terres motif l'endroit
était si mal à rider solitaire que la
légende voulait qu'il soit habité
seulement par les gee lee jane était la
seule chose dont un homme fleurs pouvait
avoir peur alors qu'ils étaient nos
trois amis n'avaient pas d'autre
solution que de s'arrêter pour la nuit
en priant que les mauvais fini les l'est
leur cause est juste
il n'avait pas de soucis à se faire
le doute s'insinuer dans le clan harman
peut-être était-il allé trop loin
les raies s'était il pouvait le sentir
à moins que ce ne soit les jim qu'ils ne
commencent à rôder pour tous
amis comme ennemi la nuit allait être
longue longue humide et froid
[Musique]
le clan des arts à manille avait déjà
fait des problèmes ou rêve on en était
pas à la première dispute avec eux y'a
rien était un diseurs d'histoires
il raconte à la dernière guerre de les
rays avaient tué avec les arabes
c'était il ya vingt ans une famille du
jeune homme sa femme et leur bébé vivait
seule dans une vallée éloignée des
autres quand novembre il vivait loin des
autres à cause et chameaux que la
famille élevé les chameaux ont besoin d'
espace voyant cette famille si isolé des
rares à manille ont attaqué le campement
la nuit ils se sont emparés des chameaux
fait prisonnier l'homme et sa femme et
n'ont tué personne
car il y avait le béguin au matin ils
sont partis avec les chameaux le bébé et
sa mère pour qu'elle n'aille pas
chercher du secours
ils n'ont rien faire là la touche et
aurait d'envoi les règles le mari était
ficelé dans sa cabane envie comme
monnaie d'échangé
tant que les voleurs ne serait pas chez
eux mais le rêve les avais entendu
parler il le tuerais apprennent alors
sans faire de bruit il a défait ses
liens tué son gardien pris son fusil et
s'est jetée à la poursuite des voleurs
il était seul et les a vite rattrapé
comme ils étaient nombreux il ne s'est
pas montré il a créé dans la montagne et
tiré plusieurs coups de feu avec l'écho
des arts à manille se sont crus attaqué
par toute une bande affolés ils ont
laissé la femme et les chameaux et se
sont enfuis comme des lâches après cette
affaire les wraith en demander
réparation ouahrani leurs chèques
refusés
nous avons pris les armes et la guerre a
duré 200 m rahmani ont eu plus de morts
que les wraith et les ont fini par
demander la peine c'est au cours de
cette guerre de représailles que le père
de fayçal a trouvé la mort
arias et mode à huy avait combattu à ses
côtés il l'avait aimée comme un frère
l'avis de fayçal seuls descendants de
leurs amis vous n'avez pas de tri pour
reviennent
[Musique]
non
après leur tir manqué deux ennemis
c'était embusqués derrière un arbre
le choix d'un arbre comme bouclier
n'était pas un hasard la croyance des
hommes fleurs veut qu'un arbre touché
meurt autant par la blessure de la
tristesse que par celle d'une balle
reçue il n'ya rien viser au dessus ou à
côté des têtes il avait vu assez de
morts dans sa vie et juré de ne plus en
faire
cela était déjà mort de peur
non
quand ils comprirent que le tireur d'en
face était assez déterminé pour faire
feu sur un arbre les deux rahmani sans
fuir pour sauver leur peau
abandonnant le troisième toujours tapi
dans les rochers
[Musique]
vous
elle seule
mme oda oui le puissant aurait
volontiers tuer cet homme comme on abat
un chien mais y'a rien avait une idée
derrière la tête et troisième les
chassèrent simplement le dernier
rahmani lui rappelant sa chance d'avoir
encore la tête sur les épaules en
réalité sa grâce était peut-être le pire
des dénouer
car cet homme n'était pas aussi lâche
que ces compagnies comme fayçal
il aurait sans doute préféré perdre la
vie
plutôt que de rentrer chez lui sans son
fusil
[Musique]
le sang n'avait pas coulis l'honneur de
fayçal et il a vu désormais un guerrier
à rahmani portait sur lui la honte qu'il
avait engendré et l'on pouvait éviter
une escalade de violence avec un esprit
de vengeance on n'obtient que des morts
et les pleurs des familles cariat
voulait proposer la paix o'hara magne
moda où il n'était pas complètement
d'accord alors garia lui expliqua qu
avec une dague d'un côté un fusil de
l'autre on était à égalité
on avait fait preuve de courage et
l'honneur était sauf
[Musique]
le maître du ciel leur avaient donné la
victoire maintenant il fallait qu'il ait
de la paix à revenir entre deux clans de
fleurs devenus rivaux le plan de yar ya
et des simples il partirait seul mot
daoui effet salle resterait sur le rejet
pendant qu'il le défendrait ya rien y
retrouver un ami qu'il avait chez les
arts à manu ensemble ils tenteraient
d'enrayer l'inévitable conflit qui
s'annonçait mode oui était convaincue
par les paroles de yar ya quand a fait
salle il avait compris que les raisons
de ce départ était lé seul raisonnable
[Musique]
la paix et la guerre sont eux sur
jumelles à guy lesage la paix est un
trésor
mais la guerre et son gardien chez les
rays ont conservé la mémoire d'une
guerre qui avait duré 30 ans combien de
mort avait-elle fait de part et d'autre
le sort de nombreuses vies est entre les
mains de cette année sont gérard ya en
même temps c'était un ennemi si la
nouvelle de ce conflit dans la montagne
s'était répandu dans les vallées cet ami
pouvait bien aussi le tuer
c'était pour ça que y'a rien et est
parti sans hasard que son ami le tue au
nom n'avait plus d'importance aux yeux
de ya rien ce qui comptait c'était de
tout tenter pour que la paix demeure
[Musique]
enfin soit contre les soirs rien parvint
à la cahute très solitaire et très
inspiré nos doigts qu'on appelait aussi
le pénétrer les salutations d'usagé
ayant été faites de part et d'autre
cariat dit qu'il avait une affaire
urgente à lui confier mes mots doit
hommes fleury digne musulmans refuser de
l'entendre tant que son hôte n'aurait
pas accepté de partager quelque chose
avec
y a rien été signe que baudoin ne put
refusé son invitation
en outre il n'avait rien avalé depuis de
choyer même où le dessin labo finalement
d'y arias en dit peu hameau dois me
mahdavi embrassait tagme na l'abri des
paiements son clan avait pas serré par
leurs actes isolés risquez de déclencher
une guerre des lamantins une dague dans
un souci dans l'autre pas de s'inverser
partage ou un kaoua avec son ami mot
doit s'était mis dans une impasse
les lois d'honneur des clans quant aux
visiteurs qui a partagé le pain et l'eau
elle une immunité de 4 à jouer même s'il
en avait une envie mot doit ne pouvait
plus qu ia ria sans trahir ce code ya
ria par déférence ne pouvait rien
ajouter sans le français
evans intérêts du capitalisme et est
éliminé marat l'a finalement mots doit
décider à campet était préférable à la
grèce
[Musique]
la gasoline
on
bien avant que leur nez chasser la nuit
les deux amis partis pour lever du jour
il était parvenu sur la terre des jeans
leur idée est que d'imposer un cessez le
feu
il fallait faire vite il fallait que les
belligérants éteignent leur rancoeur il
fallait qu'ils baissent les uns
[Musique]
s'il était à rahmani mot doit était
avant tout homme flammes il avait un
coeur généreux de ceux qui préfèrent la
mort à la trahison d'une parole donnée
et une fille ce qu'il avait promis lancé
l'ordre de cesser le feu dans la
montagne à ceux de son clan si aucun cri
en retour ne prouvait que les
belligérants étaient toujours en vie il
fallait tirer une fois appelé encore
tirer une deuxième fois
bakhit jeudi à rabat que tu me vois
dialogue
il n'y a pas de fusil keaton de la même
manière les gens des clans savent
reconnaître mieux que la voix des hommes
celle de leurs fusils des arts à manille
reconnurent celui de mode roi ce qu'ils
entendent y est ensuite de sa part les
désarment à tout à fait
et il fut ce qu'il fut un matin d'entre
les matins le tribunal des éleveurs se
réunit pour tenter de régler le conflit
qui avait ébranlé la tranquillité des
montagnes on appelait cela un mage rice
les plaignants étaient assis à gauche
les accusés a droit un ancien de chaque
clan pour la sagesse des débats le
grand-père de faysal représenter les res
l'oncle du jeune meneur défendre est né
à ramène dans les cas de guerre ou de
paix on remettait la justice entre les
mains d'un chef de clan neutre mais
celui qu'ils avaient choisis étaient
respectées par chacun pour sa grande
expérience
l'usagé voulait que ce soit les victimes
plaignante qui expriment leur billet en
premier et y'a rien propose à la paix
contre la restitution de la date de
fayçal et la reconnaissance des
frontières ancestrale du territoire des
rêves
le juge entendait ensuite les accuser
mot doit affirma qu'il n'avait connu de
cette affaire seulement ce que lui en
avait raconté son ami à rien si arias
avait dit la vérité
alors les arts à manille devait des
excuses horas après avoir entendu les
deux parties le juge demandait aux
plaignants ce qu'il voulait en
réparation de la fia et des pertes
qu'ils avaient subi le grand-père de
faysal rappela que son clan était prête
à la guerre mais si des arts à manille
reconnaissaient leur frontière et
rendait la dague il ferait là ensuite le
juge entendait la réponse des accusés à
ses yeux les demandes des rêves semblait
raisonnable et on est alors loin que des
jeunes rahmani pris la parole et ce
qu'il dit n'avait rien à voir avec la
question du territoire
il prétendait même que jamais ses neveux
n'avait dit à fayçal quand ils s'étaient
rencontrés que ce territoire appartenait
aux arts à manille non ses neveux
n'avait jamais remis en question les
frontières des rêves pour rien c'en
était trop le mensonge de cet homme
il n'avait d'égal que la lâcheté la
fourberie de ses neveux et les avait
volé la date de fayçal par la force
ça c'était la vérité malin
l'oncle avait révélé que pendant leur
dernière guerre le père de faysal avait
tué le père du jeune meneur arts à
manille depuis 20 ans ce fils demandé
vengeance en hommes fleurs il a attendu
que fayçal atteignent le statut d'homme
pour agir le jour au grand père lui a
offert sa dague a été ce jour c'était
donc pour une très vieille histoire une
histoire de vengeance qui datait d'une
guerre ancien que faysal avaient été
molestés humilient
et le territoire deyres remise en
question les narrations par la vo le
juge avait dû menacer de quitter le
majlis pour que le calme revienne
et avant de faire part de son verdict il
demanda à chacun de faire la promesse
qu'ils le respecterai et en appliquerez
sa sentence et chacun fit sa promesse
amman et demain sa pole de l'année
le juge donne alors son conseil
d'oublier les vieilles querelles de
cesser de ne regarder que ceux qui
opposent pour voir ce qu'il nie il
devrait désormais vivront frère et faire
vivre le très haut a placé les hommes
sur terre pour qu'ils jugent des choses
apparente il s'est réservé à lui-même le
jugement des choses secret
[Musique]
il ya encore vingt ans aucune route ne
m'a né au pays des hommes fleurs
aujourd'hui la civilisation atteint les
pierres et la poussière des anciennes
pistes dans leurs pays longtemps cachés
dans les montagnes à prêter leurs
propres lois leurs propres tribunaux et
les hommes fleurs refusait toute
ingérence extérieure à leur clan
[Musique]
au cours des millénaires les hommes
fleurs n'ont eu d'autres lois que celles
de l'hospitalité de l'honneur et de la
joie de vivre la modernité les a
maintenant gagné
entre-temps allah et son prophète
mahomet ont estompé les anciennes
croyances dans les dieux de la nature
des éléments primordiaux et des génies
des plantes
aujourd'hui la prière est sacrée et la
loi coranique veille au pays de l'islam
fondamentaliste
autrefois le voyageur chanceux pouvait
encore à percevoir la beauté légendaire
des femmes fleurs aujourd'hui sont
voilées et se cache au regard étranger
six femmes sont le dernier mystère de ce
pays se mêlent et se démêlent sans cesse
nécessité guerrière et désir de paix
comme deux amants séparés
combien de temps encore pourront nous
contemplent et des hommes fleurs se
maquiller les yeux de cole il couronné
leur front des couleurs et des parfums
de la vie
m
[Musique]
bien
si la vie est éphémère la terre demeure
m
[Musique]
-
le territoire des wraith pour un temps
restera intègre grâce aux efforts de
fayçal de yahia le philosophe de mode a
oui le puissant et de leur amour mot
doit le pénétrer
et si dense c'est pour célébrer la
victoire de la tête sur la guerre
[Musique]
mais là
au pays des hommes fleurs on ne tire
jamais eu raison en ce jour de liesse ce
n'est pas contre le vent plantier c'est
sur l'ennemi invisible
[Musique]
qu'on apprenne aussi loin que porte
l'écho des balles
ici on est prêt à montrer aux importuns
la manière dont ils seraient reçus et
traités
si d'aventuré ils venaient chercher
querelle
car ici contre l'inconnu deux clans sont
maintenant unis pour le meilleur et pour
le pire
le clan des wraith et le clan des arts à
manille célèbre d'une nouvelle alliance
il fait aussi la naissance d'un nouvel
homme fleurs le trait est mais il
traitait maire hervé salle celui qu'on
appelle aussi le vivant
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'histoire des wraith était
à amani poursuit son chemin de vallée en
vallée comme un murmure poussé par le
vent
[Musique]
dans les hautes montagnes du assir si on
écoute bien souvent on peut l'entendre
chanter et raconte les histoires de
fayçal le téméraire
au pays des bédouins
des déserts et des mirage le pays des
hommes fleurs n'a pas encore livré tous
ses mystères
[Musique]
vous
là
[Musique]
elle